all right let's get started okay
okay so part two of our discussion so
now we're going to focus on post hoc
explanation methods right
so let's think about explanations a bit
more because unlike what we have been
talking about so far uh there is no
longer a model that is trying to be
inherently interpretable here or produce
things that can be interpreted right so
now we are in a situation where we
essentially have this kind of a complex
classifier we can't touch the classifier
or that's the setting that we are
working with we don't want to change
anything about this classifier but
there's an end user and we need to sort
of provide some interpretable
description of this model's Behavior to
the end user right so the explanation
will be an interface between this
complex model and the end user so it has
to almost have two Key Properties so the
first thing is the explanation should
Faithfully describe the behavior of this
classifier right so if the explanation
is not correctly describing Model
Behavior then essentially it's not
useful even if it is interpretable to
the user right that's one piece of it
and the other side of it is whatever we
are producing should be able to be
should be interpretable to the end user
right so those are the two pieces and
then the sort of complexity in this
entire scenario comes from what exactly
do we mean by understandable to the end
user and that depends quite a bit on the
nature of the end user themselves right
so whether they are machine learning
experts whether they're domain experts
all of those aspects and you know that's
something that we are going to also talk
about a bit more later all right so for
example when we think of oh we just need
to provide an interpretable description
of the Model Behavior that could look
like any of the following for example
you could just send all the model
parameters Theta and if this is somebody
who is building a model themselves or
you know is a scientist research or
engineer who under understands machine
learning they may be able to make some
sense of it right so that's some form of
like providing that person more
information or you could basically send
many example predictions and say that
you know for this example this is the
output I get for such examples is the
output I get and so on or you could
summarize with a program or rule or a
tree all these kinds of constructs that
we talked about earlier or you could
sort of Select most important features
or points that are influencing the
prediction or you could sort of describe
how to flip a given model's prediction
so all of these are possible
explanations of a complex model to an
end user right now which one is more apt
depends on exactly what your application
is and also who your end user is right
so for example I can't send all the
model parameters Theta to a doctor and
assume that they would make any sense of
it right but whereas if I tell them
things like most important features they
might be able to use that information
okay
so
very high level the literature on
post-talk explanation methods can be
divided into two classes of explanations
so one is local explanations and the
other is global explanations I think the
names are pretty descriptive but like
let's just walk over what these means
right so local explanations the goal of
these these explanations are these
methods is to explain individual
predictions of the model right so if we
have one prediction how is that
prediction coming about or what are the
factors that are impacting that
prediction now global explanations on
the other hand they try to describe to
the most part complete behavior of the
model so they try to give a global
picture of the model's Behavior okay so
their goals are also slightly different
again you know because of the way they
are sort of like thought about uh local
explanations typically help us unearth
any kinds of biases or models Reliance
on spurious features Etc in a given
local neighborhood of an instance
whereas Global explanations help shed
light on Big Picture issues or big
picture biases affecting larger
subgroups in the population
right and uh again I guess it kind of
follows from what we are discussing
earlier so by local explanations help
vet if individual predictions are being
made for the right reasons uh Global
explanations help with if a model at a
high level is suitable for deployment
right so these might seem like somewhat
trivial issues but like in practice
these things are important because for
example before we even deploy a model so
there needs to be let's say in a
hospital or you know in a court system
and so on there needs to be like
approvals or high-level authorities need
to approve that okay these models are
you know fine enough to be deployed
right so for in that case we can't give
them you know a bunch of local
predictions of like 1 million points and
say now use this to wet your model so
for them the global description is very
important so that they can see a big
picture view of what's going on right so
in practice these differences play a
very significant control in enabling
certain applications and practices
versus the others okay
all right so this is broadly the
needed to look at so first we are going
to focus on local explanation methods
under that you know the thing about you
know sort of what we discussed so far
and how it ties to this is you might see
some familiar constructs here that we
already talked about in the context of
inherently interpretable models right
whether it is the rules whether it is
you know feature importances whether it
is prototypes these constructs will be
repeatedly occur through this entire
literature whether you're talking about
inherently interpretable models or Post
drug explanations
okay but these bring a whole new set of
challenges with them because you know we
are considering approximations of
another model here right okay so let's
jump into the first and a very popular
class of local explanations which is
feature importances
right uh so I'm sure some of you have
heard of this method called lime or shap
you know because these are pretty
popular and if you're looking for I want
an explanation method you might run into
repositories and you know packages which
have implementations for these right so
this this was I think one of the initial
methods that came up within this area of
post-hoc explanation methods and the
algorithm or the actual method is
actually very simple and intuitive right
so what this is trying to do again
remember that there's a local
explanation which means we are trying to
explain individual predictions of model
just one prediction at a time right and
the way this method works is let's say
our goal is to sort of explain the
prediction of the model on that instance
that you see on the screen and the
models the underlying models decision
surface is this kind of complex
non-linear surface that you see uh you
know sort of below the plus Mark and the
way you sort of proceed with this
algorithm is that you take that point
let's call it x i and then you perturb
that point several times and you
basically generate instances around x i
right so you add some random gaussian
noise to X and then you generate a bunch
of instances in the local neighborhood
of X or x i
all right so now use the underlying
model to predict the labels for each of
these perturbations that you generated
right so now take the underlying model
and determine the predictions of each of
those points and then
uh weigh these samples according to the
distance to x i right so points that are
closer to X I will get higher weightage
and points that are farther away from X
I will get lower weightage and
essentially you do that waiting and then
you basically fit a simple linear model
like a linear regression or a logistic
regression on these weighted samples
okay so that's pretty much what this
does and now your simple linear model it
gives you a bunch of coefficients or
weights associated with different
features and that becomes your
explanation because that provides
feature importances
okay so the algorithm is super simple as
you can see so you literally take a
point
put up it a bunch of times generate a
local neighborhood and get the model's
predictions on that local neighborhood
and then fit a linear model on those
instances and their predictions right so
that's it
okay
all right so uh this paper also kind of
gives some interesting examples which
have become like classic examples of
thinking about explanations and their
necessity and we have already seen some
of this in our motivation for example if
we just look at the predictions made by
let's say some models we might see that
oh there's only one mistake so maybe the
model is actually doing extremely well
right so it's predicting everything
correctly there's only one image where
it's making a mistake but on the other
hand once you see the explanations
output by this method what you realize
is what we have essentially built is a
snow detector
right so this kind of insight can only
be obtained from uh explanations
okay
so uh alongside lime another popular
method that often comes up when you
think of or when you actually even
search for post talk explanation methods
is called shap right so shap is also
trying to play along the similar
intuitions as that of lying and it has a
lot of connections with lime but at a
very high level what shap is trying to
do is estimate marginal contribution of
each feature towards the prediction and
you sort of average this contribution
across all possible permutations
so what I mean by that is let's take an
example where we have uh three features
so X1 X2 and X3
okay
and now we want to come up with this
feature importance according to shapley
values for X1 right so we want to
determine what is the contribution of X1
so the way shop operates is actually
very simple but you know scalability
issues arise which which needs a lot
more tricks to happen in the background
for that to work out but essentially the
idea is you compute how much does the
prediction change prediction of the
underlying model change with or without
X1 for different permutations of the
features right so first you see okay so
with no features what will be the
prediction if you add X1 what will be
the prediction okay then with X2 alone
what will be the prediction if you add
X1 what will be the prediction what's
the difference and again the marginal
contribution of adding X1 to X3 right so
essentially for each such combination
you are Computing what is the result of
for example adding X1 to the mix
minus what is the result of not having
X1 in the mix
right
so you do this for every possible future
permutation and then you sum up and
average all those marginal contributions
so that's what will constitute the
shapley value or the contribution or
importance of each feature and this is
how you can compute it but as you can
see you know once you get into
permutations a lot you know this will
become a very hard problem to solve
computationally and there are tricks for
approximating these and so on but you
know that we are not going to get into
but here is the high level intuition
okay all right
now in this class also there are some
rule-based methods which are pretty
popular so one of them is anchors which
can be thought of as a rule-based
variant of line we talked about right
and anchors essentially relies on the
same tactics as that of line so what we
do is if you want to uh sort of think
about the explanation of an instance X
you perturb that instance X to generate
the local neighborhood just like you did
for lime and then what you do is you try
to find a rule that sort of correctly
covers that local neighborhood right so
again if you recap and think back to
this decision sets or rule sets that we
were talking about there also the goal
was to find some rules which nicely and
correctly cover a certain space or the
data set in that case here we are just
trying to find the rules uh that
correctly cover the local neighborhood
so the intuitions are the same uh we're
not going to go over the details of the
algorithm but roughly you are trying to
find rules that cover the local
neighborhood correctly so for example
let's say here is a data point and this
is the prediction of that data point uh
so lime's explanation will basically
tell you the importance and the
direction of the importance positive or
negative for each feature whereas anchor
explanation is basically that rule that
is sort of covering the local
neighborhood
okay
okay so the next class of local
explanation methods that's very popular
especially in images and computer vision
is sale in cmaps and saliency Maps again
these are also going to Output some kind
of feature importances but they sort of
do it in a very different way than
alignment shop let's take a look at
those okay
so with saliency maps the idea is that
let's say you have this complex model
and you know you can input images to
that model and then it basically makes
predictions in this case the model is
saying the image is that of a junko bird
the question that you're asking is what
parts of this image are most relevant
for the prediction junko bird
right so that that's the question that
you're asking and you're hoping to get
an output like this which basically
highlights the important pieces within
the image that the model is relying on
when making that prediction junco bird
okay
all right
okay
so uh just for the sake of I think
thinking about different classes in this
settings so either you could think of a
binary class model or a binary
classifier where there's a function f
mapping you know to class one or if you
have multiple classes you can think of a
class specific logic right and F5 is a
class specific Logic for class I okay
so there are several methods in order to
generate these saliency maps that we
just saw and a lot of these basically
play on gradients rights or derivatives
to put it more simply so for example the
first method which actually uh was
popular for a while before of course
then peoples are detecting issues with
it and so on is this input gradient uh
where what you are trying to compute is
basically the gradient of that class
specific logit right so gradient of that
function or the underlying model f of x
with respect to the instance X whose
prediction you want to explain so what
is the reason behind doing this it's a
very simple intuition right so you want
to see how much does the output change
or how much does the underlying function
change when you make a small change to
the given input data point
right or each of the features of that
input data point essentially
right if y changes a lot as a result of
changing one particular feature in your
input points Vector then essentially
that feature is very important for y
right so that's it you know rate of
change of Y given X that's essentially
the principle you are using and you are
Computing this and you know things that
have higher gradient values here will
basically mean that the features are
more important
okay
all right
so uh if we sort of take this example
and visualize the heat map where red
indicates the regions of higher
importance and white is regions of less
important here is a kind of outputs that
were produced by these input gradient
methods right and you know several
challenges exist with something like
this first of all this is visually noisy
and somewhat difficult to interpret and
there are also other issues such as
gradient saturation that have been like
documented but mainly if you look at
this image you know we can see that it's
somewhat noisy we are not sure what to
make of it what is the model looking at
is that what the model looking at and so
on so in order to fix some of the issues
with these methods there was a variant
proposed called Smooth grad and what
smooth grad does is essentially it
averages the gradients of noise the
input it does not just take X and
compute the gradient of the function
with respect to X it basically takes X
perturbs it n times and then computes
the gradient of the output function with
respect to each of these perturbations
right and then you average all that so
you are essentially creating a smoothing
effect in this case when Computing the
gradient right and so this is the output
for the same image with smooth grid as
you can see there is you know you can
make a bit more sort of sense out of
this it is not as noisy as what we were
seeing with gradients right
okay
so the next approach that was proposed
again along these lines was that of
integrated gradients and the idea here
is again you're trying to sort of do
some smoothing of the gradients here but
a slightly different kind of smoothing
than averaging the gradients right so
the idea that's being used here is do a
path integral which is basically compute
a sum of the interpolated gradients so
you'll think of this as there is some
baseline input X tilde you can think of
that as like just a black image right
with nothing on it so there is some
baseline input and the way you are
thinking about gradients here is you are
interpolating gradients between the
Baseline input and the point okay so
you're basically going through all the
gradients in between and trying to
compute the integral of all those
gradients on that interpolation
okay and you know again the output
started becoming more and more clearer
as people improved these methods one on
top of the other
and there are also a few other methods
for example there is gradient times
input which is you don't just compute
the gradient you also do a DOT product
with the point x itself so that's the
element wise product of you know
gradients and the input points uh so
that is what produces like images like
these uh and there are more variants for
example there is lrp layer wise
relevance propagation grad Cam and so on
but the point of these kinds of methods
is they use gradients in some way or the
other and create like you know different
versions of smoothing of these gradients
to sort of come up with the saliency map
or the explanation and this is a pretty
popular class of post talk explanation
methods that are commonly being used in
a variety of applications including
Healthcare like for example using chest
chest x-rays to sort of detect tumors
and so on people are also using these
kinds of methods for generating
explanations there
okay
so the next class is prototypes and
example based post-hoc explanations
so under this broad area again there are
several approaches so there's just
probably a running note for everything
so I think we are touching some
representative approaches in each class
or each category there are several other
approaches that you know due to time
constraints we are not able to get into
but the goal is to give you a high level
idea about each class right okay so with
the prototypes or example based
explanations there are two key methods
that have been proposed under this
category at a high level these class of
methods use examples whether they're
synthetic examples or natural examples
to explain individual predictions right
so the first work is by priscilliang and
his student pangwei which is on
influence functions the goal here is to
basically identify instances in the
training set that are responsible for
the prediction of a given test instance
right so if you have a test instance
which of the K training instances were
responsible for this prediction that's
what you want to identify and the second
is called active activation maximization
where the goal is to identify again
examples whether synthetic or natural
that strongly activate a specific
function of Interest or a neuron of
Interest okay so let's talk about the
first approach a little bit and then go
to the second one uh so here as I was
just explaining this is the first
approach what we want to ask here is not
just look at what pieces of the image
are influential to the prediction but
ask the question of which training
points have the most influence on the
test class for this particular point and
the prediction right
so for example in this case you know the
answer might be some other images in the
data set that are of a junko bird right
and the approach or the technique that
is that was used in this work is
actually borrowed from a very classic
technique in robber statistics which is
titled influence functions and the goal
of while while in the classic statistics
literature that this was obviously not
used for quote-unquote explanations uh
there's something called as Cooks
distance in uh you know classic lobus
statistics literature the goal here is
we are trying to estimate the influence
of each of the points in the training
data set on the model parameters right
so in order to do that for example if I
want to estimate the influence of this
point on the model parameters one way is
you know I remove the point out train
the model again see how the model
changes right but that quickly becomes
complicated if I have to do it for every
point so there is an uh there is a very
popular measure called as Cooks distance
which actually gives an analytical
expression for computing the change in
the model parameters when you sort of
like remove a point from the data so
essentially you're Computing the
influence of that point right so what
this paper does is essentially take that
basic idea of Cook's distance and apply
it to a modern machine learning setting
of thinking about explanations and
influence of training points on test
points and so on right so for example
let's say x j is basically a training
sample Point uh sorry Z J is a training
sample Point z i is basically indicating
any point I in the data set and there's
also some test Point Z test okay so for
those of you who are familiar with
machine learning this is like a classic
empirical risk minimization sort of
objective function and this is what we
used to learn model parameters right so
these approaches they sort of think
about this slightly differently in the
form of an updated ERM solution so let's
say our goal is to estimate the
influence of the point Z J on the model
then you can sort of think about that
kind of an updated solution and if you
set Epsilon to minus 1 by n that is
effectively like you know sort of
removing the point Z J from the data set
okay so this is a slightly generalized
formulation so that you can think about
the influence of the point Z J on model
parameters so basically they use that to
sort of compute uh this kind of influent
influence of the training points on the
model parameters right so that that's
the main goal so ultimately you want to
get to this where you want to compute
the influence of a training Point Z J on
the model parameters and as you can see
that involves Computing a Hessian and
once you have that then you can estimate
the impact of ZJ on the loss of Z test
which is a test data point by using that
expression okay
and this paper also talked about a bunch
of explanations here one is you can sort
of compute self-influence of a
mislabeled examples to understand what
is happening right so if a point is
misclassified if we compute the
influence of that point on the predictor
then we can see or potentially
understand why that misclassification is
happening or we could potentially
diagnose like a possible domain mismatch
where a point is out of distribution and
you know we can sort of see that by
looking at the training examples that
are influencing the prediction of this
point and also because this is helping
us identify influential points in the
data potentially if we poison or if
adversaries poison those points then
they may be able to change the predictor
maximally right so there are several
sort of like other applications uh
boiling down into adversarial examples
and other kinds of literatures of this
approach so there are a couple of
challenges with this kind of approach
though so one is scalability because it
involves Computing a Hessian as we just
saw right so that can be hard in
practice uh and the non-convexity of the
objective we are looking at that also
turns out to be challenging in practice
and there are some other papers that try
to fix some of these issues okay the
other approach that we considered under
this setting is activation maximization
so this approach again the goal is to
identify examples that activate a neuron
of Interest right so and then you know
the different implementation flavors
here are so one is search for natural
examples within a specified data set a
trained data or so that strongly
activate a neuron of Interest or
synthesize examples that may not
necessarily exist in the original
training data typically why optimization
procedures like gradient descent that
strongly activate a neuron of Interest
right so either use optimization to find
synthetic examples or search in your
data set to find the example
so here are some examples that were sort
of like output by using each of these
approaches
the top row is basically examples chosen
from the data set itself right so which
were activating certain neurons in a
particular intermediate layer strongly
and the bottom is if we use optimization
to find such examples what they look
like so clearly there is a big
difference between the kinds of examples
you see in both cases right so in some
sense the top you can sort of see it's
showing some baseball images or you know
stripes and then the bottom is like it's
a clear sort of like ambiguity there
that whether it's a baseball or Stripes
is unclear so the images that you would
get when you think about natural
examples versus synthetic can look quite
different
okay
right okay so now the last class of
local explanation approaches is
counterfactures which actually has been
popular because of other kinds of
applications than the ones that we have
been talking about right so at a very
bare minimum level what is a counter
factual explanation counterfactual
explanations tell us what features need
to be changed and by how much to flip a
model's prediction right so for example
in this case what features in this image
of a crested are [ __ ] need to be changed
and to what uh in order to get a red
face camera
right so why is this important or like
where is this useful this is an
interesting question because a lot of
this area of research is thinking about
applications in banking and financing uh
because as I was saying earlier like
regulations like gdpr are sort of
focusing on those areas as their
preliminary areas of enforcement so this
these explanations have become popular
because of those areas so just to
understand a scenario here let's take a
look at this example where there is a
loan applicant who has submitted their
loan application to a bank which has a
predictive model which determines if
that person should get a loan or not
right so in this case if the person is
denied a loan instead of just saying
that the person might actually benefit
if we tell them what they need to do in
order to change their profile and
reapply for a loan so that they have
more success next time they reapply for
a loan right so now how do we generate
such explanations is basically this area
of counterfactual explanations also
referred to as algorithmic recourse so
these terms are often used pretty
interchangeably in the literature today
so whenever you hear one or the other
you're basically referring to the same
thing right and the recourse or the
counterfactual explanation takes a form
of something like this feature and then
the change to the feature right so for
example salary increase salary by 5K you
know pay credit card bills on time for
next three months so that's the kind of
changes that are recommended using these
algorithms
okay so the strategies for generating
these kinds of uh explanations are many
but they have some common underlying
principles so I'm going to touch upon
those first before I get into other
details okay so generating
counterfactual explanations at an
intuitive level you can think of it in a
very simple way right so your goal is
there is some point x on this negative
labeled area of the model decision
boundary and you want to find another
Point uh in the positively labeled area
of the decision boundary that X can
morph into right so that's the problem
so intuitively you can think of it as so
now take the point x and keep perturbing
it and pushing it towards the decision
boundary and once it crosses the
decision boundary stop and say x should
become that point in order to get a loan
right now the the question here though
is if I take X and start perturbing it
towards destined boundary it can either
go this way and become this point cf2 or
it can go this way and become this point
c f 1. which should it become right so
that is basically where different
approaches differ on so in some sense
the proposed algorithms for solving this
problem differ on how to choose among
these candidate counter factuals and the
second thing is how much access is
needed to the underlying predictive
model
okay whether they can work with a black
box or whether they need access to the
gradients of the underlying model
right
okay so we'll get into some of the
details of these approaches now and just
go in sequence to see how they sort of
go from one to the other uh or actually
let me pause here and see if there are
any questions before I do that and go
into more details
there is there is one question from the
uh chat here that might be relevant to
what we were talking about just
previously
um and the question is generally what do
you think of anthropic's recent softmax
linear units paper
um does it give more hope for building
more interpretable model architectures
or should we be focusing on these
post-hoc explanations that you've been
talking about yeah I mean I I would say
all the efforts uh you know whether
you're trying to sort of do it at the
level of the model whether you're making
models more smoother right or whether
you're using post-doc explanations these
are all efforts in the direction of
making something more understandable in
some way or the other right so at least
in my personal opinion the answer is
probably not one versus the other uh but
I think you know sort of having a more
clearer characterization of when to go
to that and when you know would that
fail and in that case would something
else help So currently and we'll talk
about this a bit more as we go towards
the end of this I think all these
approaches are useful it's just that I
feel what is needed is a clearer
understanding instead of saying it's a
this versus that battle a clearer
understanding of here is when this would
be more useful and here is when
something else might be more useful I
think that's where we should be headed
because this is something that I get
asked a lot in different forums as to
also like you know maybe we should never
use post-hoc explanations because there
are some disadvantages which we'll talk
about at length uh in the afternoon
session uh but I think the answer is
probably not to pick a side but like to
see when each approach would be useful
okay all right
um so let's move forward and try to look
at each of the individual approaches in
this area
so here is basically the core objective
of like a lot of approaches that try to
generate counterfactual explanations
so the idea is given a point x
we want to find a point x Prime such
that the distance between x and x Prime
is as small as possible
and the model's output on X Prime is a
positive label
right so you want to find the closest
instance to the original instance you
started with such that you know these
two are pretty close but also the label
of this new instance that you're finding
is a positive label right and then you
ask X to change into X Prime basically
that's the idea okay so X Prime is
called your counter factual and X is
your original instance and D can be some
distance metric whether it's l 2
distance or you know some other kinds of
distance Manhattan distance and so on
okay uh so the choice of distance metric
is also important because if you're
thinking about a practical application
this can dictate what kinds of
counterfactuals are chosen right of
course in terms of your optimization
methods and stuff you know it might make
some difference but I think there's more
of something that would make a big
difference in practice
okay so the first paper that actually
touches upon this area is uh presented
by Sandra wachter and her colleagues and
they use normalized Manhattan distance
here but you know other papers which
build on it have started using L2 as a
classic distance metric because it
improves the optimization pieces
okay so now uh so that that's basically
your minimum distance counterfactions
right so this is the objective typically
when solving this objective walkthrough
and even other methods in this area
essentially try to make this constrained
optimization problem as an unconstrained
one by bringing up these constraints
into the objective itself and then they
basically you know solve this
differentiable and constrained version
using optimization algorithms like Adam
with random restarts right so as you can
see there's already a non-convex problem
so you would need random restarts in
order to uh have a chance at getting to
the global minimum
all right so this particular method
actually requires access to gradients of
the underlying predictive model so the
predictive model can't be a total Black
Box where you're just seeing the
predictions of the model you need to be
able to compute the gradients of the
model
right so here are some examples that
this method produces so for example it
says you know if your LSAT score was 34
you would have some predicted score of
zero and you know if you change your
LSAT score to some value then this is
what would be your predict predicted
score right so the interesting thing is
just the way this method is implemented
it's suggesting people to change their
race in order to get a desired outcome
right so obviously something like this
is not feasible to act upon in practice
but also it is highly unethical to sort
of do these kinds of things right so
that's why there are further approaches
with sort of built upon this approach
and that's the work by usted netal where
they change this objective to now uh
enforce that X Prime which is the
counterfactual that we are picking
should belong to a particular set a
which can be be thought of as a set of
valid counterfactions right so in that
set a for example you will not allow
changes to raise or gender or any other
sensitive attributes uh that are you
know unethical to use okay
okay
yeah
all right so here as I was just talking
about this is a set of feasible
counterfactions that is often given by
the end user and changes to race and
gender and these kinds of things are not
feasible right and there is also an
additional thing that you see there that
has changed from our first objective
that we considered which is instead of
distance this approach is now
considering costs so in some sense
instead of just saying I'll compute an
L2 distance in this sort of data space
it's saying you know some features might
be harder to change for a person in
practice than others right so let's try
and account for them like maybe for
somebody who is living in a particular
place it is easy to increase the size of
their house or the square footage of
their house but not their salary and for
somebody in another place the vice versa
could be true how can we incorporate
those better when recommending these
changes so let's not just look at the
distance in the input space but look at
the cost associated with changing
certain features when prescribing this
kind of a recourse right and as a first
sort of a cut you know solution to this
this particular approach sort of models
cost as a log percentile shift which
basically models this aspect that
changes become harder when you are
trying to make changes at like higher
percentile shift right so changing from
90 to 95 might be much harder than going
from 50 to 55 percentile for example
okay so this of course what this
approach does several follow-up Works
including some of ours actually try to
learn these costs by asking users about
their preferences so for example we did
some work where we basically go and ask
users people are bad at assigning this
cost straight up to a feature but if I
tell them would it be easier for you to
change your salary versus the square
footage of your house they can give a
yes or no answer and do pairwise
comparisons well right so how to go from
there to inferring such costs is of
course some follow-up work to this that
we and other researchers have done
yeah okay
so basically this approach or this paper
only considers the case where the model
is a linear classifier so that's and
they also have theories surrounding this
in order to say that whatever you're
getting out of this is a good solution
for a linear classifier so the way they
solve this problem is they formulate it
as an integer program and optimize it
using cplex so this approach actually
requires complete access to the linear
classifier they need the weight Vector
in order to compute this kind of a
recourse or a count of actual
explanation right so which may or may
not be available depending on the
setting you're working with
okay all right so now the question is
what if we have a black box or a
non-linear classifier uh instead of a
linear classifier now one potential
solution could be something like you
know generate a local linear model
approximation for example using an
approach like line that we talked about
earlier and then once you get such a
local linear model then apply you know
this framework in order to get the
recourse that's one approach it of
course has its flaws and Depends heavily
on the quality of that local linear
model approximation itself but you know
that's the sort of potential way to use
this approach with a non-linear
classifier right
and this is an example of how the output
from this particular approach looks like
so basically it has some features to
change and what's the current value and
what are the required values so
essentially that's the kind of output
that these approaches give right uh so
now here like let's say there is this
value called as current depth and you
want to decrease that but one more piece
to notice is that in reality in practice
changing one feature without affecting
the other might not always be possible
right so what do I mean by that for
example we just told this applicant
reduce your current depth from you know
3000 to 50 to 000 and let's say after
one year this applicant comes back and
say oh my current debt has reduced to
thousand Now give me a loan and then the
model might say oh but your age also
increased by one and this recourse is no
longer valid for people whose age has
increased by one along with your depth
reducing right so now you know it's very
important to account for for these
feature interactions when generating
counter factuals but how do we do it is
basically the next practical problem
which was addressed by some works right
and the solution is kind of what you
might be expecting by now which is you
play with the set a which is basically
the set of feasible counter factuals
that you allow when trying to pick a
particular count of actual for a person
right and in this case you will now sort
of resort to using structural causal
models so for example let's say you have
access to the causal process that is
generating the data which captures all
the interactions between different
variables in the data and how they
interact you can use that model and
allow only those changes which are
permitted according to that causal model
right so that's one approach which was
suggested in in literature but the big
question is what if we just don't have
access to the structural causal model
which is often in the case because with
any real world data set you really get
access to a full-fledged causal model of
the underlying generation process there
are also sort of other works which try
to work around this problem one approach
basically tries to say if you have
imperfect causal knowledge like you kind
of know some relationships you will try
to infer the others and then leverage
that or the more recent approaches that
have become popular are based on
variation Auto encoders so the idea is
ultimately you want a realistic enough
counterfactual right so that's your goal
with all this even when you look at
structural constraints and so on you're
saying my counter factual should not
look unrealistic so how do I generate
more realistic counterfactures whether
it is using the causal graphs or whether
it is using some other approach right
and the other strategy or an alternative
strategy that was sort of considered or
you know is becoming more popular these
days is so the goal is the generated
counterfactuals should lie on the data
manifold so the approach taken is
construct variation Auto encoders to map
input instances us to a latent space
right and then you search for counter
factuals in that latent space and once a
counter factual is found map it back to
the input space using a decoder okay so
this basically helps with a bunch of
things including the fact that your
input feature space may not always be
smooth or continuous whereas the chance
of your latent piece being that is
higher so you're likely to use a
gradient descent and get to a point uh
that you want to give as a counter
factual uh more nicely in your latent
space than you might be able to do so in
your input space partly because input
space could also be discrete and you
could have features that are just binary
valued or like rank ordered and so on
right so that's that's what this
approach is trying to tackle okay so
with that we are pretty much at the end
of our local explanation approaches
module and again between these two
approaches local explanation approaches
have gained a lot of popularity compared
to even Global explanations in the
literature and also in terms of adoption
okay
so before I get into Global explanations
and go over some of the approaches there
I'll pause here briefly to see if there
are any further questions about local
post-hoc explanations
yeah so you you go back by basically
using the decoder so when you develop
the encoder and decoder so decoder will
map this point back to the input space
and that will help you generate like
realistic enough points in the input
space
correlations with good teachers
everybody goes with because of advances
correlation maybe I don't know it's safe
male pregnant you might get this type of
strange right so the hope is that I
think because this approach does not add
anything more on top of you know the
decoder to ensure some of these things I
think the hope is that when you do this
encoding decoding process or especially
the encoding process you're preserving
some of these kinds of relationships in
the data because they may appear
prominently but as of now this approach
does not add anything else to the
decoder so if something gets missed in
terms of like how the encoder is
capturing these relationships you might
still run into those problems but the
hope is that that will be taken care of
by the encoding yep
okay
all right uh okay so let's go to Global
explanations and the goal here kind of
contrasting from what we were saying so
far uh is to explain the complete
behavior of a given Black Box model
right so in some sense we want to
provide a bird's eye view of the Model
Behavior and you know the why do we need
this is it can help us detect the big
picture biases persistent across larger
subgroups for example the biases
persistent against let's say a minority
group or a particular gender or race you
can sort of see those better with this
kind of a bird's eye view right that's
the goal
um and well one might think well I have
local explanations I know how to compute
them why can't we just inspect these
local explanations and then learn about
the big picture Behavior as we can
already see intuitively that's very hard
to do in practice because if you have 10
000 points manually inspecting all these
local explanations and trying to make
sense of them is going to be extremely
challenging from a cognitive overload
perspective for people right so that's
why we want a better summary of the
local explanations and that's what
Global explanations are trying to do
okay
so in some sense Global explanations are
complementary to local explanations in
terms of the view they take on the Model
Behavior
okay
so we already talked a little bit about
some of this so I'm not going to go over
that again instead let's look at some of
the categories of global explanations
so people have again thought about
different uh you know approaches to sort
of generating Global explanations so one
is think of them as a collection of
Representative local explanations uh so
we'll discuss how to do that the other
is representation based explanations
which is a slightly different category
than all the sets of things that we have
seen so far and then there is model
distillation which means you are just
trying to sort of use a simpler model to
approximate this existing complex model
as accurately as you can given the
constraints of the expressiveness of the
simpler model and then you know with
respect to counter factuals what can we
do with global explanations so those are
the different approaches that we'll
touch upon okay
all right
um so let's think about the first
approach which is global explanation is
a collection of local explanations right
so how to generate a global explanation
of a black box model so the high level
idea is generate a local explanation for
every instance in the data using one of
the approaches that you've discussed we
have discussed earlier and pick a subset
of K local explanations and then return
that as a global explanation right by
saying you know instances which look
like this have this kind of explanation
that's how you're thinking about a
global explanation but I guess the key
question in terms of the exact
algorithms you use are well what local
explanation technique to use and how to
choose this subset of K local
explanations right so to this end
different approaches were proposed and
again let's talk about this first in the
context of line uh so that we can
understand how to pick a subset of K
local explanations right recall that
lime is used to explain a single
prediction so essentially if we are
looking at that point that is labeled in
the black color it can provide you a
linear model that approximates the
behavior of the underlying model in the
locality of that point right again we
have been discussing about this
challenge of like it's hard to examine
all the explanations so how do I pick K
so that's the question right so these K
explanations are a subset of K
explanations that we pick should have
two characteristics so one is they
should be representative in some sense
they should summarize the model's Global
Behavior and the other is they should be
diverse they should not be written in
descriptions right so for example let's
say if I have picked the point already
that is labeled in black color and its
Associated explanation in my Global
explanation I would rather pick the blue
point and its explanation next instead
of the red because the red is
essentially the same way linear model
right given that you are trying to only
pick K points and their explanation to
give a global summary you don't want to
pick redundant explanations right so now
how do we do this essentially this can
be formulated as a submodular
optimization problem and a greedy
approach can be employed in order to
pick such explanations right so you
basically start with start at some point
pick an explanation and then maximally
try try to pick explanations that differ
maximally from this explanation that you
have already picked right so that's the
way in which you can intuitively think
about this process and you know this
approach is model agnostic which means
you don't need access to gradients of
the model functional forms of the model
architecture of the model all you need
is you should be able to throw a data
point at the model query the label of
the point and get it right so that's
true even of lime and shap and some of
these other approaches by the way that
distinction often of how much access you
need to the model becomes important
again in practice because in certain
settings you may not have access to say
model gradients or model architectures
or their functional forms okay
all right so similarly there is another
approach called SP anchor so which is
essentially what we you know thought
about for lime it's an analogous
extension but for anchor algorithm and
it produces rules right so use the
anchors algorithm to obtain these local
rule set for every instance and then use
the same procedure to greedily select a
subset of K local explanations and then
return them as a global explanation okay
all right so let's talk a little bit
about representation based approaches
because these have gained a lot of
popularity in recent times but have also
encountered a lot of pushback okay and
you'll see why in just a bit uh so the
goal of representation based approaches
is that you're trying to derive model
understanding by analyzing intermediate
representations of a deep neural network
right so in some sense your main goal in
doing so is to see how much do models
rely on Concepts that are semantically
meaningful to humans so what we want to
go from where we want to go to is so far
we are saying okay you give me a bunch
of input features and I'll tell you the
importance of each of these input
features on the prediction right but
what we are saying is what if I as a
human will tell you a concept that's not
a feature in the data for example let's
look at this scenario right so let's say
we are looking at this particular
prediction where you have the image of
the zebra and there's a model that takes
this image and predicts the label
correctly right now if I want to ask the
question how important is the concept of
Stripes to this prediction
where Stripes is not an encoded feature
in the feature space I know what Stripes
is as humans we know what that concept
means right but the model does not for
for the model it's all pixels right so
it can only compute importance on the
pixels in the image but now you're
saying I have a concept in my mind how
important is that concept to this
prediction okay so how to do that is
basically this area of representation
based explanations okay
so the one of the approaches that's
popular in this area is called TCAP and
the way this approach approaches this
problem is as follows right so let's say
now our goal is to estimate the
importance of or influence of the
concept called stripes on the
predictions of a model okay so for this
first of all I need to tell the model or
tell your algorithm what Stripes even
mean right so to this end I'll give my
model two sets of images the top set of
images that you see is all capturing the
concept of stripes in different ways
right and the bottom set of images are
just random examples which have nothing
to do with stripes so I'm giving two
sets of images one from the stripes
class and the other from a class that is
not Stripes like a random set of images
right now I pass these two sets of
images through the model whose
predictions I'm trying to explain and
you know know let's let's pick a
particular layer let's say you know the
health layer which generates a bunch of
representations so let's say our goal is
to basically determine how does the
concept of stripiness in some sense
influence like the representations and
the health layer of this network okay so
let's say that that's the goal or you
know in fact there is more we want to
say about the prediction but we can
literally do the approach that I'm going
to discuss at each layer and then sort
of you know compute the Aggregates over
all the layers to determine what is the
influence of the stripiness concept on
the output okay but let's just pick the
health layer at this point and let's
take the representations generated by it
that layer by the model for each of
these images both the stripe images as
well as the random images right and you
know let's say that that's what we are
basically getting at the health layer
for each of these images
now we build a linear classifier which
basically separates these two classes of
vectors so all that linear all this
linear classifier does is essentially
say uh for this particular image so here
is the vector set or here is the vector
that this would you or it is just
basically trying to separate the class
is this Vector belonging to uh you know
the stripes class or is this Vector
belonging to the random class right so
that's what it is doing okay uh and then
now using this sort of linear classifier
that we fit we can actually compute a
vector uh that is orthogonal to the
decision boundary and moves in the
direction of the concept of Stripes
right so if you see this vector v c l
it's orthogonal to the decision boundary
it is pointing in the direction of the
stripes class and away from the random
class right so why are we doing all this
exercise our goal goal is to basically
get a vector representation of the
concept Stripes right so if I tell
Stripes to the model like you know
Stripes is a concept that makes sense to
me but not the model Now by doing all
this I generated a vector representation
in the space of the representations in
the health layer that corresponds to the
notion or the concept of Stripes okay so
once we have such a vector then we can
leverage this and compute gradients do
all other things in order to get the
importance of this Vector on the outcome
right so that that's basically the logic
that's being employed here so just to
recap this whole process the goal is
you'll start with two sets of images one
set of images represents the notion of
Stripes the other set of images
represents random examples and then you
get the vectors for all of those images
from the model from each of of the
layers actually and then you try to
build in your classifiers that separate
the two classes of vector activations
and you take the vector that is
orthogonal to the decision boundary
pointing in the direction of the concept
of interest and then you compute
derivatives by leveraging this Vector to
determine the importance of the notion
of stripes on a given prediction right
so the key thing here is we went from
having the concept of stripes in our
mind to getting a vector which
quantifies what is the notion of stripe
to the model
right
okay great
so uh let's move to the next class of uh
Global explanation approaches this is
called Model distillation and has
actually been there for quite a long
time and also is popular among
especially these uh you know tabular
sort of like data environments uh so the
goal here is that you have this
predictive model again f of x that you
want to explain or provide a global
explanation for so let's say you have a
bunch of data points here that you can
throw at this model you can get the
predictions of this models on each of
those data points okay you have access
to you have query access to this
predictive model and you have access to
the data set and the corresponding model
predictions now you take all this pass
it through an explainer algorithm and
then sort of approximate these
predictions or rather try to mimic these
predictions using a simpler
interpretable model uh which is you know
sort of a lot more easier to understand
right so essentially take these models
predictions and input instances and try
to approximate or mimic the predictions
of this model but now using a simpler
model right and if you recall we talked
about Gams a bit earlier when we were
discussing inherently interpretable
models so Gams have actually been
proposed as a global explanation
solution for a lot of these black box
models so the idea is that again take
the points take the predictions try to
fit a game on these predictions right of
course how accurate would these sort of
fitting Gams to these kinds of you know
this setting would depend on again how
complex are the predictions to capture
using the functional forms of Gap right
sometimes you can be successful
sometimes it might be hard so that
depends on the nature of the data and
the complexity of the boundaries in the
data right
so we have discussed at length about you
know this kind of outcome variable and
how the outcome variable is affected by
you know the different values of the
input variable and so on so I'm not
going to touch upon this but essentially
here is what you will try to fit so what
you do is you have input points you have
the corresponding model predictions you
try to fit a gamma on it that's
essentially what is happening here
okay
all right and as you can imagine now
decision trees have also been considered
as this kind of you know fitting the
simpler models to try and approximate
the predictions of the complex models
right so that was also something that
has been explored by some of the prior
approaches and you know once you have
some class of rule-based approaches you
can imagine people would think of other
classes like rule sets and so on so
those are also used in order to
approximate uh these kinds of like mimic
the predictions of the complex models
right so in some sense I'll just give
you one example of a stylized versions
of decision sets that at some point we
used to work on so here as you can see
so this is the summary of what a complex
neural net is doing this is actually
quite accurate particularly in this
particular data set and this particular
setting but these decision sets are also
I'm calling them stylized because
instead of just having some rules this
is sort of ordered in like a two level
hierarchy where the upper layer
represents subgroup description so
that's basically the description of the
properties of certain groups in the data
and then the inner rules basically
represent what the model is doing on
those subgroups right so there is a very
clean separation between what is a
subgroup and then what is a what is
model logic in some sense right and that
is very helpful in sort of seeing at a
high level what the model is doing for
like different subgroups in the data and
all of these including segmenting the
data into subgroups and finding rules
that explain modern logic in that
subgroup all of these are automatically
generated and there is ability to
customize these okay
so for example uh so an end user can say
something like explain how this model
behaves according sorry across patient
groups with different values of smoking
and exercise so you know that smoking
and exercise are like the features of
Interest so you can customize that set
of rules that you saw using these two
features of Interest that's exercise and
smoking and now the rules are split
according to different values of
exercise and smoking right as you can
see not all values sum because you also
want the rules to be compact so it's
deciding how to divide the part
partition the space or divide the space
based on features of Interest ok uh and
how to sort of go about these things or
generate these things uh a lot of this
can actually be sort of inspired by and
you know that surrounding theme we
talked about some of the objective
functions with the decision sets uh so
we could employ some of the pieces that
are similar to that others are a bit
different from that for example you will
try to minimize the number of instances
for which the explanations label is not
equal to the model prediction right so
your the sets are producing labels you
want those labels to match the model
predictions and then you will also
minimize the number of duplicate rules
applicable to each instance so that
there's no confusion in terms of like
the explanation for each instance and
then you of course minimize the number
of conditions in the rules uh you also
put constraints on the number of rules
and the subgroups which is the outer
Rule and you can also allow for
customizability by saying outer rules
should only comprise of features of of
Interest which are given by the user
right so these are some of the tricks
and this turns out to again be a similar
problem but this time with like
meteorite constraints so you can use
like a smooth and out version of some
local search algorithms that we talked
about previously uh in order to solve
these kinds of optimization problems
okay
and along similar veins actually you can
think of summaries of counterfactuals so
for example we talked about this a bit
earlier as to how to generate
counterfactual explanations for
individual users or individual instances
in the data now you get a bunch of such
counterfactuals or recourses now the
question is there is a decision maker or
regulatory Authority who is trying to
figure out if this particular model and
the associated recourses are reasonable
or if they have some bizarre biases that
are going on that we can't figure out so
how to help them right so in some sense
how do recourses permitted by the model
vary across various racial and gender
subgroups are there any biases according
again certain demographics and the
biases in this context could look like
you're asking some people to change a
lot of features whereas you're asking
some other people to just change very
little right and you're doing or the
decision is somehow getting hinged on or
based on what racial subgroup they
belong to or what gender subgroup they
belong to then it's a problem right so
let's just maybe see this example so for
instance uh you are trying to uh so here
is basically the sort of this kind of a
summaries of counterfactuals what this
is saying is for different subgroups
again the subgroups are generated sorry
captured by the outer rules and for each
subgroup you're seeing what needs to be
changed for that person to sort of get a
known right so for example if ratio's
racist caucasian gender is male so
you're asking that person to change has
job from no to yes right the rest is
fine uh and similarly uh drugs from yes
to no right on the other hand for
Caucasian females you're asking them to
change two features in the second rule
instead of one for the corresponding
Caucasian meal right so similarly if the
race is different you're actually asking
people to change a lot more features now
this kind of a bias is a problem because
you're making one subgroup do a lot more
work or put more effort when getting a
recourse but this you can only know when
you have a summary of all the
counterfactures or the recourses that
the algorithm is generating for a given
model right so that's that's why these
summaries can be useful
okay
all right so again the outer rules that
you see just similar to some of these
other summaries that we have looked at
earlier are the subgroup descriptors and
then you know the inner rules that you
see are the recourse rules which tell a
person or other which tell us what
features need to be changed and from
what to what
okay so now you know if the regulator
sees that this is in fact what is
happening with respect to the recourses
they can actually realize that okay this
is biased it's requiring certain
demographics to act upon lot more
features than the others right and the
decided time this case will be that we
want the recourses that are coming out
in these summaries to be correct so in
some sense we want to minimize the
number of applicants for whom prescribed
recourse does not lead to a desired
outcome right so that you don't want to
capture those things in the summary
because that's an incorrect summary and
then the other thing is you want
recourse coverage where you're trying to
minimize the number of applicants for
whom recourse does not exist so in this
set of rules you don't see a recourse
for certain applicants we want to
minimize that set of people okay and
then we want to minimize the total
feature costs as well as magnitude of
changes in the feature values right so
that's basically like the generic way of
by the way the summaries of free courses
that we saw the counterfactures that we
saw that summary itself can be used to
prescribe recourses to individuals too
right so it can have a dual purpose it
can serve as a summary to tell a
regulator what is happening and you can
also use the exact same thing to
prescribe recourses to individuals so
it's a dual approach right given that
it's a dual approach we are also trying
to focus on minimizing the total cost
required to implement the recourses that
are being prescribed for each group as
well as the magnitude of the changes
that are required right and of course we
need these summaries to be interpretable
which means we can't let this sort of
summary uh you know rule set bloat up so
we want some constraints on the number
of tools number of conditions in the
rules number of subgroups and we can
also provide customizability by ensuring
that outer rules only comprise of these
features of interest to the stakeholders
and those features don't show up in the
inner rules for example right
okay so again it's a similar kind of
problem as the one that we just talked
about with the two level decision sets
without the recourse or without the
counter factuals so that's what it turns
out to be ultimately okay
so I think with this we are almost at
the end of this module so what I can do
is take a few minutes of questions and
then maybe we'll pause here and then
reconvene uh back right after lunch